everywhere she turns the crisis is in
evidence
Maria vallverdu guides a tour group
through Barcelona's old town where
Catalan history and the current
political upheaval appear to vie for
attention protest banners and flags hang
from buildings were normally only
laundry is strung out to dry like many
locals the historian is outraged that
Madrid is moving to enforce direct rule
on Catalonia the current political
situation is like some
eighteenth-century ruled by decree it's
a step backwards by 300 years even if
Prime Minister Rajoy claims he hasn't
revoked Catalonia autonomy and
everything will return to normal I don't
believe it the next stop on the tour is
the historic Palace of the Generalitat
the seat of the regional government
journalists from all over the world are
here reporting on the standoff between
Barcelona and Madrid
opinion is divided on whether
Catalonia's bid for independence
violates the Spanish Constitution maria
vallverdu is horrified over Madrid's
hardline course and no longer rules out
military intervention I suspect Madrid
will use force to seize control of the
regional administration because the
Catalan government is not going to give
him now and simply hand the keys over to
rahoy and the situation is growing
increasingly tense at this protest a
Spanish police helicopter becomes the
target of collective anger more than
400,000 people are here demanding the
release of two jailed independence
activists
[Applause]
the streets will always be ours they
chant many Catalans feel abandoned by
Europe this year is a peaceful
demonstration not fooled by politicians
but by the people I had hoped that
Europe would hear the cries of the
people and help us because our demands
are justified in a cafe
Maria's group takes a break she sees
herself as liberal minded and until now
opposed independence for Catalonia but
Prime Minister or a choice tough stance
has made her change her mind there are
lots of people like me who actually
didn't want independence but now feel
compelled to change sides because of
this blatant disregard for democracy in
a place where conversation normally
revolves around soccer and the weather
these days it's the Catalonian crisis
that's on everyone's mind we're seeing a
split in society
I'm worried most about the economic
impact for my company and employees
because there's currently a lot of
uncertainty in Catalonia
after three hours maria valve a dual
concludes her tour
the city seems its usual self with its
mix of Spanish folklore and the Catalan
architecture that draws millions of
tourists each year and yet today there's
a nagging sense that Barcelona may be on
the brink of change